[Music]
let me just listen to my block
it's quiet usually the one dream's up
there screeching
there's so much stuff going on just got
me thinking about all the people i care
about the most
there's a breeze off the hudson and just
when you think you're sick of living
here the memory floods in the
morning light off the fire escapes the
nights and bend the park blast the big
punt tapes
it's the story of a block that was
disappearing once upon a time
in a far away land called washington
heights
who's gonna notice we're going say it so
it doesn't disappear
washington heights
look who's home bad change is happening
on the block since you've been at school
when it came to dreams we had to keep
scraping by
ice cold aguas i believe when we get
into these crazy hypotheticals you
really want some breath then go ahead
create a set of goals
pick a business school and pay the
entrance fee and maybe if you're lucky
you'll stay friends with me
they used to say if you work hard you
live by the rules
the things will come and those things
will heal you
i'm not gonna sit here and give you some
fairy tale
ignore anyone who doubts you because
this place
this is it
i just want to see the whole world
through our eyes
let's go show them who we are
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the moment when you do better
than me because you can see a future
that i can
sonny you're late you know you love me
[Music]
once we get going
[Music]
oh
once upon a time
in a far away land called washington
heights
say so it doesn't disappear washington
lights up from washington heights up at
the break of day i wake up and i got
this little punk i gotta chase away
pop the great at the crack of dawn sing
while i wipe down the awning
hey y'all good morning
it's a story of a block that was
disappearing the genius
is back yo he should just ask her out
right now
on your shirt
smooth operator
we all had a swinito and when it came to
dreams
we had to keep scraping by maybe this
neighborhood is changing forever
maybe tonight is our last night together
however
i just want to see the whole world
through our eyes they're talking about
kicking out all the dreamers
it's time to make some noise
we had to assert our dignity in small
ways
little details that tell the world we
are not invisible
this is the moment when you do better
than me because you can see a future
that i can't
you made all of this this is me
they used to say you work hard
you live by the rules the money will
come
the things will come you ready
i've been saving up all my pennies in my
piggy bank for this day today's all we
got so we cannot stop
the best days of my life and i built my
little dream my swinicus
but what is
[Music]
so